five of the nation's top scientists were
preparing to review the peer-nominated
candidates for a prestigious science
award the american geophysical union's
fellows program when they discovered
that something was terribly terribly
wrong with the nominations they
discovered that the nominees
were
white guys
the fellowship was open to women and
black people and every other type of
person too but it just happened that
none of them were interested and
nominated so instead of going ahead and
just picking the winners like they were
supposed to do the scientists on the
selection committee decided to cancel
the process
altogether in the words of helen fricker
one of the panel members the mere
presence of the white men quote was kind
of a bit of a show stopper
meanwhile a t calls white people the
problem a florida school board takes
elementary school students to a gay bar
and the biden administration promises to
pay illegal aliens nearly half a million
dollars each
for breaking our most basic laws
welcome to the spooky wild world of
identity politics i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from big bad b-robb
who says the quote-unquote christian
university that i work for is working on
charging students for getting kovid
until they get the fouchy algae what
happened to the virtue of prudence
well be rob no man can serve two masters
and a whole lot of christian
universities when push comes to shove
when when you really come down to the
tough issues
choose a different religion they choose
the religion of liberalism they choose
the religion of progressivism locism
whatever you want to call it over their
nominal
faith
and it has led to a lot of terrible
social problems just on a really basic
level
this kooky religion of liberalism and
progressivism
it's it's causing prices to jump up all
over the place whether you're at the
grocery store whether you're at the gas
pump but i've got a solution to that
last problem that would be get upside i
am so happy to tell you about get upside
this app came just in time right now gas
is going through the roof
i am going to save you
at least 25 cents for every gallon of
gas that you
pour
every time you fill up just download the
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
knowles k w l e s get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that
means up to 50 cents cash back per
gallon don't pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
down load the app for free use promo
code knowles keno wlas to get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to 300 bucks a month in
cash back there's no catch your cash
gets right added into your bank account
cash out any time to your bank account
to paypal to an e-gift card for amazon
or other brands download the free get
upside app use promo code knowlescanwlis
to get up to 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank that is code
knoll scanner wles
you're welcome the scientists
they can't win their award because
the nominees are white guys
that would be very bad now just they
just happen to be white guys if you just
if you look at
the scientists they just
disproportionately are
white guys it's not
like there's a lack of incentives and
encouragement for other people to go
into these fields they just don't
and so but that's really that's a big
problem
we need to cancel the nba awards you
know you know those nba awards that i
assume that they have at some we need to
cancel them because did you know that
the nominees are disproportionately
black guys that's unacceptable we every
there has to be exactly every
award needs to have exactly what 12
nominees black and then something like
what's 60 percent white
and uh 50 women like what 51 women and
it's all got to be exactly
representative of the population of
course that wouldn't be the case either
though
instead when you look at these awards
actually the the women the women are
less likely to be nominated or the
minorities are less likely to be
nominated but they're much more likely
to win once they are nominated to make
up for some perceived historical
injustices it's not just going on at the
science awards christopher ruffo who has
been absolutely dogged in his fight to
anathematize critical race theory
christopher ruffo has a scoop
that a t
has created a race re-education program
with certain materials claiming that
quote
racism is a uniquely white trait
and teaching employees quote white
people
you are
the problem
we've heard this for years this was even
being taught a little bit when i was in
school it was starting to bubble up when
i was in school now it is the mainstream
view
of these race hustlers that black people
can't be racist so you get someone like
that cookie rutgers professor who we
heard from yesterday on the show who
said that white people are spiritually
and morally deficient and who's that or
you hear this from nick cannon or you
hear this from a lot of black
nationalist types over the years
they can't be racist because racism we
are told by these people is the marriage
of
you know racial antagonism and power
and because we are told that
the only people with power are white
guys and the only people who can be
racist or white guys of course that's
not the truth the only group that it is
legal to discriminate against
is
white guys and to a lesser degree much
less degree white women and to a still
pretty significant degree asians
but the top of that list is the straight
white guys especially the straight white
guys who know that they are guys
and this is having an effect people are
losing their jobs because they're white
guys they're actually
a white guy just cashed in for this as
he rightly should have there was a
marketing and communications executive
who lost his job at a north carolina
health care system
and he lost his job in in his view
because he was a white guy
so this went all the way up
to a federal court
okay lawsuit starts in 2019 david duvall
says that novant health's diversity
efforts
led to him being fired
he his attorneys claimed that he was
fired out of the clear blue sky because
he was a white guy and that the move was
in keeping with the hospital's five-year
plan to boost diversity by
2020
and the jury agreed
that actually is why it wasn't just him
by the way
the chief legal officer the medical
group president the chief information
officer the patient experience officer
and the president of haymarket medical
center were all replaced by a black
person or a woman in the year to year
and a half after he was not saying
that the black people or the
women
were not talented did not but
it is certainly the case that when a
medical group goes out there and says
we're going to have a diversity plan
meaning we're going to replace the white
people specifically the white guys and
then within a year or 18 months
you have
many of the top
white guys just all fired what because
they all just suddenly got bad at their
jobs and replaced specifically by people
according to their race and sex that is
obviously discrimination and this
federal
court awarded him
10 million as well they should have good
for them there are
some squishes
who believe that this sort of racial
and sexual discrimination is okay
the left loves it the left supports it
outright but even some squishes on the
right will say it's okay
because of historical injustices you
know
so there was slavery slavery was very
bad
so therefore we need to discriminate
against white guys today
or uh
i don't really know what the gripe that
the women are making is you know the
women tried to kind of copy the civil
rights movement the second way feminists
tried to copy the kind of black civil
rights movement as did a lot of groups
there's a wonderful book on this by mike
gonzalez called the plot to change
america it's about how the ford
foundation and other very powerful
left-wing institutions just copied the
strategy of the black civil rights
movement and tried to apply it to groups
where it was
uh less credible and authentic but it
worked and it turned everyone into a
victim except for white guys now the
reality is everyone has some historical
injustice that they can claim
i i am of italian extraction largest
mass lynching in american history was
against italians right 11 italians were
killed in new orleans in 1891. okay
where's my check where's my where's my
job where's my
where is my special treatment because of
the it's the largest mass lynching in
american history
how dare you minimize that how dare you
not give me my historical grievance
tokens
right a lot of these squishes believe if
we just
entertain
this kind of politics a little bit if we
just yeah look discriminate against the
the white guys and the asians for some
reason why the asians i don't know but
you discriminate them in university
discriminate against them in university
admissions you just do that for a few
years then it'll all even out then it
can go away
sandra day o'connor on the supreme court
a republican nominee to the supreme
court said
that look this affirmative action stuff
it's pretty bad you know it's not it's
probably not constitutional but we're
going to do it for a little while just
to fix
the social problems and then we'll get
rid of it and then we'll get rid of it
will we is that what's going to happen
this is 15 days to slow this bread this
racial and sexual discrimination that's
increasing in our country right now
is 15 days to slow this we're just gonna
do it for a little bit guys just to even
a few things out just to
lower the curve just to stop the slow
the spread of the racism or whatever but
then it'll stop
oh yeah we're on day 591 of of 15 days
to slow the spread
how long since we were told okay
affirmative action it's run its course
okay this discrimination against people
on the basis of their race and sex it's
run its course it's not going away you
got to fight it tooth and nail
absolutely should
stop this sort of thing you know
there are people cashing in
on this and it's not just the white guys
people are cashing in on identity
politics
across
identity groups
this one white guy who lost his job he's
kind of the exception usually it doesn't
go that way but everyone else is cashing
in on victimhood including illegal
aliens right now to whom the biden
administration is promising to pay
upwards of half a million dollars
for breaking our laws that's a lot of
money i bet you could buy some really
nice window shades with that kind of
money which is why you could actually
buy nice window treatments for much less
than that kind of money if you go check
out hunter douglas i never appreciated
before just how important window
treatments are for a house i don't know
i'm a man when i was a bachelor i never
thought about this at all
then i get married i get a house i move
to tennessee
it's it's one of the most important
features of your whole house because
it's going to control how the light
comes into the house and the light it's
going to completely transform the way
that you live in your home i'm not
overstating it folks
i i've just been going through it for
the past several months and when you get
those right window treatments everything
looks beautiful hunter douglas will help
you do just that with their innovative
window shade designs gorgeous fabrics
control systems so advanced they can be
scheduled to automatically adjust to
their optimal position throughout the
day so you don't even need to think
about it they diffuse that harsh
sunlight they cast a beautiful glow
across the room do not waste another
second with harsh ugly light in your
home get these wonderful hunter douglas
window treatments they're incredible
hunterdouglas.com
knowles head on over there right now
take advantage of the season of style
rebate savings event hunterdouglas.com
knwles head on over there for limited
time savings offer expires december 6
2021.
there is a report out right now
that the biden administration is
considering payments of 450 000 dollars
per person
to people who crossed the border
illegally and were separated
by the trump administration you remember
the kids in cages and the family
separation and all these slogans from
the trump administration
that they all blamed on trump even
though it was a policy that dated back
to clinton bill clinton and the flores
settlement
a policy
that was in effect under barack obama
today we have kids in cages under joe
biden but they all blame trump for it
and now
these people are being rewarded
with almost half a million dollars
could you use half a million dollars i
could use half a million dollars that'd
be nice
but in order to get that i guess we need
to go
to
guatemala or some
other country
walk all the way up through mexico flout
the most basic laws of the united states
and then demand where's our check give
me my check this is so deeply offensive
to
the people of the united states to our
system of laws to our system of
government to our democracy
that we would subsidize people to come
here
but that is what the left in this
country is doing i think this if this
goes into effect again it's just still a
report for now if this goes into
effect i think uh that will be the
firmest confirmation yet
that the biden that the democrats don't
they don't have any interest in closing
up that border they are encouraging
people to pour in because they think it
gives them a political advantage
speaking of places that it should be
illegal to go a public school public
elementary school in florida
just took students on a field trip to a
gay bar
a gay boy this is rosie's
bar and grill it is a place for sassy
fun
according to their marketing materials
they took the kids there for a field
trip and showed them all the pride flags
and the rainbows and they were wearing
kind of little rainbow
t-shirts when they were there
and they had a presentation about
how great gay bars are i guess
this uh
this
decision is shocking a lot of people
because they think oh my gosh how can
maybe the high school students but the
elementary school students how could you
take them to a gay bar
this is actually perfectly natural
i mean it's not this kind of education
would not be natural but the broader
premise that you're going to
inculcate
your moral views in your students that
is
part of education education is in part
learning facts learning dates learning
battles learning math learning
arithmetic learning how to read and
write but
part of education is teaching people
ethics morality how to live right the
point of public education is to make
people good citizens and now part of the
reigning ideology of the regime is the
rainbow stuff is the idea that any
sexual desire you have you should pursue
it is the idea that if you're a man who
thinks he's a woman then you really are
a woman i mean that's on our passports
now
so of course we're going to teach
elementary school kids this it's only
natural if they were in catholic school
well a lot of catholic schools have gone
pretty lit these days too but if they
were in catholic school
they'd they'd have mass they would pray
they would learn the sacraments they'd
learn about the saints and the ten
commandments
but they're not they're in lib school
they're in woke school and so they're
going to learn
the morality of of the left
they're going to learn the
anthropology of the left that's just
natural if you want to stop this kind of
thing it's not enough to just say hey
don't take kids to gay bars that's crazy
you you have to go a lot deeper than
that you say hold on what are we
teaching this is what this is what the
the parents showing up to their school
boards is all about it's not just about
one or two crazy incidents a kid field
trip to a gay bar or even that horrible
rape in virginia it's not just about
those incidents it's about the whole
thing it's about the whole problem that
parents are being cut out of their kids
education that parents are not allowed
to teach the kids their moral views
their ethical views their their
civics right there the country that they
want to live in that's not being
permitted anymore and the school boards
are getting increasingly aggressive
about this
there was a parent who showed up to a
school board
meeting
who was not permitted to speak
until he doxed himself
i just want to remind everyone this is a
business meeting of the school board
it is not a meeting that belongs to the
public
each speaker is asked to state his or
her name and address for the record
failure to do so will result in an
individual not being allowed to speak
john can you give us your name and
address please uh my name is john
wicklund i live in mankato could i get
your address please john um i'd rather
not since
[Music]
and i get so much uh property damage and
eggs and everything else
from
fun people and their friends
you need to give your address i live on
excuse me i live on fifth street
[Music]
thank you all
right so are our kids safe
what a thug this woman is what a mobster
what a bully
she's saying there's a new rule you got
to state your address before you speak
to the school board this i think this is
called the matt walsh rule
this is the rule to keep matt walsh and
other conservatives from going to just
random school districts around the
country so okay so they're implementing
it this is a way to keep those pesky
conservatives out
this guy's in the district
this woman seems to know this guy
she says excuse me sir
you have to state your address
because i don't want to state my address
people are attacking my house and egging
my house and it's just inviting people
to come come after me
yeah right you're gonna have to state it
though
you know but you know who i am you know
yeah right uh-huh what's your address
okay i live on this street
oh yeah what's the number
come on you know what street i'm you
know that i'm in the district you've
yeah what's the number you gonna say it
buddy
it's a nice house she got there
sure would be a shame
if something
happened to it that's how serious they
are about this stuff
that's how serious they are about the
racial and the gender
ideology
okay because it's not a lot of squishes
misunderstood this and they thought oh
this is some silly distress well the the
most naive of them thought
this is just a way to make up for
legitimate historical grievances against
black people brown people native
americans women homosexuals
transgenderists uh i don't know asians
well asians actually get discriminated
against hispanics immigrants
the disabled that would you know any way
that you can possibly claim victimhood
it's just a legitimate way to even out
the playing field that was the most
naive view it's never about that
then the second most naive view was the
view oh it's just a silly distraction
okay they're gonna have their
kind of weird sexual and racial stuff
but it's not a big deal you know
whatever roll your eyes at it it's not a
big deal no no they're dead serious
about this they'll dox you if you
question this they'll fire you if you
question this they'll ruin your life if
you question this
because this is the animating ideology
of the whole regime it would be as if in
the old america
you questioned
democracy or you questioned the
constitution or you questioned the
founding fathers
you would be
ostracized for that
you would be looked upon with suspicion
you could you'd be a con it'd be like in
the old regime if you were
if you were a communist you could be
prosecuted for being a communist and
many people were
while the same thing is happening now
it's just you'll be
harassed and ostracized and fired and
prosecuted even if you're a
constitutionalist
if you're a conservative they are dead
serious about this stuff speaking of
oppressive government bodies
right now
in
china they are suppressing christianity
and islam
they're suppressing any
religion forget it just ideology any
religion especially that is
a threat to the regime there
and our corporations american
corporations that now make a lot of
money overseas
are
capitulating they're going along with it
apple has removed a popular bible app
and a quran app in china
after the communist party there
decided that the apps violated local
laws because they hosted these religious
texts so the bible app
bible app by oliver which has over a
million downloads and quran majeed which
is used by millions of muslims were
taken down by apple for compliance
issues not complying with the officially
atheist government of china
no man can serve two masters gets back
to what we were talking about in that
comment at the top of the show
and our woke corporations
even american corporations like apple
don't seem to have any loyalty to
certainly not to principle certainly not
to
god certainly not to
ultimate things
they don't really seem to have very much
loyalty to their countries to the united
states
these corporations trash the country all
the time
their loyalty is to the almighty dollar
and they will sell out anything they'll
sell out their god for 30 pieces of
silver
that's very bad and unfortunately
the left doesn't care about that the
left is part of the cultural revolution
but the right has adopted a lot of that
language too especially really from the
1980s through
the 90s 2000s 20 teens especially now
it's starting to change
it seems that the right in america had
adopted this materialist mammon
worshiping position we all want a robust
economy we all want a
thriving wealthy flourishing country
but that's not the be-all and end-all
politics that is in service of something
greater that is in service of a good
virtuous stable flourishing country and
right now it'd be very difficult to
describe the united states that way
speaking of religion
there was a very spooky article in the
new york times
there's a there's a halloween thread
throughout the show it's very subtle i
don't know if you've noticed
very spooky column by charles blow in
the new york times
headline the married will soon be the
minority
the mayor and this is true for the first
time ever
it appears as though married adults are
trending to become a minority of the
adult population
this is because people
are delaying
adulthood right they're
perpetuating adolescents
they are not choosing to get married and
stay married they are not choosing to
involve their religious community in the
state and the public in their what they
now deem to be their personal romantic
life
i don't think that it's it's that
marriage is on the decline because a lot
of people are taking holy orders that
would be a good alternative to marriage
you know becoming a priest or a nun or
something but that's on the decline too
it's because people are just
a little bit well one they're a little
more selfish
i think that's certainly true that's
just the ideology and then this creates
other problems for people who sincerely
want to get married or who sincerely you
know there are plenty of people out
there who are lonely who actually want
to meet someone or who want to meet a
good person they don't want to just
settle for some derelict or degenerate
and they can't do that
it's like the dating pool has become a
little bit poisoned we live in swipe
culture now where it's just so easy to
move on and treat people like
commodities
and so what the new york times is asking
what charles blow is asking is should we
continue to reward and encourage
marriage
he says quote as a society we have to
start asking ourselves whether it is
fair and right to continue to reward and
encourage marriage through taxation and
policy when fewer people
disproportionately black ones are
choosing marriage or finding acceptable
partnerships so see he adds the racial
element here too which is that right now
over 70 of black babies are born out of
wedlock
right this is
a terrible situation for the black
community they're also extremely high
rates of abortion which is a worse
condition for for black people but
marriage has plummeted in the black
community
that's bad that's a sickness especially
within the black community it's
particularly pronounced there but it's
really pervasive throughout all of
society and so what charles blow is
doing is he's taking that sickness
to be
an argument for further destroying
marriage
you know i hate to say that we were
right
we conservatives but we were right we
were right about everything remember
when we said if you redefine marriage
through uh you know pretending that
there's some right to
define marriage as a union of two people
regardless of their sexual
nature
that
will destroy marriage that will not help
marriage it will not grow marriage it
will not strengthen marriage it will
just further erode marriage that and and
this erosion of marriage goes back a lot
further than just the gays right you
know you can't just blame it on the gays
it goes back to
the
no fault divorce culture that we've we
adopted in the middle of the 20th
century
this goes back to the
uh weakening of the religious
institution of marriage this goes back
to the confusion of
sex and gender roles the idea that a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle this goes back a lot
further and so what charles blow is
saying is yeah like put it out of its
misery take it take marriage out of the
yard like old yeller and just put a
bullet in the back of its head because
it doesn't mean anything anymore and
actually the existence of social
illnesses social pathologies the idea
that kids are born out of wedlock that
should be the argument for further
eroding marriage because it's not fair
because if black people in particular
don't want to get married then we we as
a society need to stop encouraging it
is marriage always the ideal he writes
and should single people pay a loaner
tax
institut no absolutely not for pursuing
it
charles blow by the way he points this
out in the column is divorced so he has
an interest here
he says he doesn't want to get remarried
now
the left loves this
the left wants to destroy marriage and
they're pretty open about it and charles
blow is saying it right here
the right wants to encourage marriage
conservatives want to encourage marriage
right we want that's why there are
incentives to get married because it's
the bedrock political institution it
leads to a flourishing country it's
better for kids it's better for
everybody
so let's create some incentives for it
but then there are the squishes and the
squishes are kind of the problem here
they're a little bit libertarian they're
the kind of the types who say let's get
government out of marriage altogether
let's who cares about marriage any two
people can sign any contract they want
who's how are you to say that it's
better for people to get married who are
you to say maybe it's better for them to
stay single and do whatever they want or
being a thrupal or a quadruple or
whatever the government has no role here
who am i to say i'm a person with two
brain cells to rub together that's who i
am
i'm a person who knows that it's better
for kids to be raised with mommy and
daddy in a stable marriage in a
committed marriage that endures until
death do they part
because i don't know because i've ever
read a history book that's who i am to
say
because i i recognize that societies
that encourage stable serious real
marriage are better societies
and because i think that the government
meaning
the people that we send to washington
that we still have some say in voting
for that are still at least
theoretically supposed to represent us
have an interest in promoting the
general welfare and ensuring the
blessings of liberty
because i don't know because i have like
even the most basic rudimentary moral
and ethical and philosophical education
so i know that there's such a thing as
the good
and that good is better than bad
and that there are true things we can
know some true things and here's one
true thing marriage is good for society
and for everybody that's who i am
squishes don't want to acknowledge that
so now you've got this really tough
fight where you've got the conservatives
who recognize gosh we've got to protect
marriage and then you've got the
squishes and the libs
and the leftists
who are all trying to destroy and
they've kind of ganged up to destroy it
why is government involved in marriage
because marriage is good okay and it's a
ver and it's the fundamental building
block of society and if our political
order does not have something to say
about marriage then it doesn't have
something to say about
anything it's inevitable the government
is going to have a role in defining
marriage one way or whether it's
to a man and a woman or a guy and a guy
or three guys in a goat or whatever it
is it's going to have something to say
about that
but
the squishes don't want to
state that
some people do though there's a great
candidate in arizona right now blake
masters running for senate boy oh boy is
this guy
focusing on
issues that are a little more important
than another corporate tax cut
in america you ought to be able to raise
a family on one single income
we used to be able to do this
something happened globalization decades
of inflation
can't really do it anymore
i think that's a huge problem so why
don't politicians talk about it
in the left they attack me they want to
say oh blake that's that's sexist
but guys there's nothing sexist about
prosperity there's nothing sexist about
acknowledging that if people can if
people have the choice most families
would prefer to have one breadwinner and
have one parent stay at home with the
kids
i'm blake masters i'm running for the
u.s senate in arizona and i approve this
message because i want you to be able to
afford to raise a family in one single
income
this guy knows what's up this guy knows
what's up okay he's he's pushing
or he's he's observing something
that i think all too often conservatives
miss which is that it's not just social
radicals who are pushing all the weird
sex stuff
it's also greedy capitalists okay
it's also
feminism
and the ever-expanding lgbt acronym and
the sexual revolution more broadly is
really good for business okay because it
keeps it first of all forces women into
the office so it gets them to be more
economically productive and boost gdp it
keeps wages down for lots and lots of
people because you've just got more
people in the labor pool it discourages
people from having kids it discourages
people from taking time off to raise
those kids it just keeps everybody
working and working in the widget
factory all right it's good for business
but our government does not exist our
society does not exist simply to serve
mammon okay there are other important
things too having a country having
borders having a way of life having
rights having liberties having strong
thriving families which are going to be
the bedrock of all of that if candidates
for office do not understand that
they're not going to fix the problem a
handful of candidates appear to
understand that and i think we should
support them you know
if you want
sports content without the woke i sure
do then become a member at
dailywire.com subscribe and use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 off also
check out the morning wire great new
morning show you know
the the new york times i'll just call
them out straight the new york times and
other left-wing outlets
they are so smart they're clever because
what they do is they have these short
little shows in the morning and they say
they're just giving you the facts in the
news but really they're giving you
leftist opinion but they have a really
soft voice they say good morning
good morning this is the new york times
i'm michael bubba and and all and
conservatives are really bad
okay now turning to other news leftists
are really good you know and that's what
they do
and that's how they control the culture
well we are not going to take that lying
down we have beaten them in the ratings
and so if you want the facts in the
warning without the leftist spin go
check out morning wire we'll be right
back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question up from
raven hi michael you mentioned you like
halloween can you give an explanation of
the holiday other than a celebration of
darkness and an opportunity for
witchcraft evangelists thanks raven i
absolutely
can do that
uh
what we're preparing to celebrate on
november 1st is all saints day right so
we're
uh this is a great holy holiday this was
uh
begun in the 8th century uh gregory iii
consecrated a chapel in the basilica of
saint peter to all the saints and fix
that anniversary for the first of
november goes back even a little further
than that in terms of the way that we
celebrate these things and so halloween
is the eve of this
feast day
um
now it it takes on it's taken on this
other kind of role you know it's not
like we all merely dress up as saints
although my little baby is going to be
dressing up as a saint for halloween and
it's going to be extremely cute
but it takes on this dimension of the
departed souls it takes on this
dimension of the saints who are in
heaven it takes on this dimension of
some spooky kind of things right
there it was alleged after the
protestant revolution by the protestant
revolutionaries that als that halloween
rather is just a christian
a catholic
version
an attempt to co-op a pagan holiday and
there were a lot of claims made like
this after the protestant revolution
about christmas for instance about
easter
and they're just not true
and i'm not i don't mean this just to
dunk on some of the protestant
revolutionaries and
pr people but it's just not true you
know the when people tell you that uh
christmas was dated to december 25th
because it was just a pagan holiday and
it was the catholics trying to co-opt it
or something or easter whatever that
that is not the case uh these dates go
all the way back
to the very beginning of the church or
very nearly to the very beginning of the
church and the reason for it for for
instance in the case of christmas is
because it was understood by the early
church fathers that a divine life has a
perfection to it it has a perfect
symmetry to it and they uh dated the
conception of christ to his death on the
cross and so what happens nine months
later you get the birth of christ that
would just be one one example of that
and they dated the
crucifixion to
uh
to the spring so
[Music]
we could go on for hours and hours about
all of these various dates um but that
is the the dating of halloween is
because of the celebration of all of the
saints i also think yeah you shouldn't
be performing witchcraft on halloween
and you shouldn't be like worshiping the
devil but making fun of the devil and
making fun of demons is extremely
christian and cool and fun uh because
there's saint john vianney great
catholic priest in france uh and patron
saint of parish priests he used to call
the devil a little idiot he'd say oh
there's that little idiot again you know
he's setting my bed on fire haha what a
stupid little idiot so i think it's fun
don't engage in the occult but have some
fun with it go door-to-door begging for
food that's extremely medieval and
traditional very very cool uh go you
know pull pranks on one another
extremely traditional we can have fun
it's totally fine uh just don't i guess
this should go without saying but just
don't
worship the devil from christian hey
michael i have a question regarding
catholic theology what does the catholic
church teach about life before we are
born on earth it is a topic that is
talked about in my church and theology
but i don't hear my friends of other
faiths talk about this thank you for all
you do at dw
love your show sincerely life is better
with faith
well the catholic church teaches that
life begins at conception
and that
it's a bit of a complicated issue i
suppose but rather than trying to
understand the body and the soul as
these totally disconnected things which
a lot of new age religion transgenderism
tries to understand it that way a lot of
ancient heresies understand it that way
it's i think far better to recognize
that your body and your soul are linked
and that really your soul
is the form of your body
to use some
jargon from ancient greece
and so when when
when it says in the bible that
the good lord knows us before we were
formed in the womb
that can mean one of two things it can
mean that
he knows us before we are created which
is a little bit confusing or he knows us
before
the process of being formed in the womb
is completed or the process of being
formed in the womb goes on for nine
months i think it makes much more sense
to view it that way similar to
uh saint thomas aquinas you know people
sometimes claim that saint thomas
aquinas says it's okay to kill babies
through abortion until a few weeks or
until 40 days or 90 days or something
like that and that's not true
uh what st thomas aquinas does believe
is that conception is a process that
takes much longer and he's basing it on
aristotelian science it takes much
longer than than we know now that it
does we know now that conception occurs
almost instantaneously we can watch it
happen right you can watch the sperm go
into the egg you can see it happen and a
life begins at the moment of conception
unlike the kooky spooky new age witchy
strange people who believe that your
soul always existed man you know and
then it just kind of goes into a body
you know and some new age cults believe
that actually your insolent doesn't
happen until after you're born so then
the soul is floating around it finds a
body and it goes into and then you die
and you're reincarnated man and
hold on just have it
you know yeah man and then we're all
just spirits you know bro and we're
floating around no your spirit and your
soul actually
does have something to do with your body
they are linked and so no you weren't
just floating around beforehand
you were created by god and you should
be very grateful for that from philip
hey michael i'm a first year molecular
biology and neuroscience phd student at
the university of denver i do
neurological research on mice but there
are some in my lab that use human
embryonic cells for their research as
well if my professor asks me to develop
my own line of embryonic human brain
cells what should i do as a christian i
know it's wrong to kill babies and do
not want to partake in the validation of
this practice in the story of joseph god
takes evil and uses it for good the best
way i can rationalize my way around this
evil is to know that i would be taking
the literal remains of an evil event and
using them for good to find treatments
for neurological degeneration what do
you think sincerely a guy who loves your
show in science but loves god more good
like like thomas more you say i'm the
king's loyal subject but god's first
the short answer is don't do it do not
experiment on human
stem cells that were derived from
aborted babies do not do it refuse to do
it
god can turn evil for good
that's god's job you should not be
engaging in evil actions in the hope
that they can be turned to good you are
not god
first of all you are not a
consequentialist i should hope
and we do not believe as christians that
good ends justify evil means
do not
do not
do it it's very bad
you can work on the mice you can even
work on the beagles i know people made a
big deal about dr fauci torturing
puppies and it was creepy and weird i'm
not saying i support it but
that is
nothing
compared to experimenting
on aborted babies you should not
you should not be cooperating with evil
evil especially in that it's kind of a
direct way
i'm very honored though i just want
everyone to take a pause and moment here
i hate to toot my own horn but i'm very
honored and flattered that a guy who's
obviously extremely intelligent and
educated and works on
neuroscience is listening to this show
that's makes me feel like a very cool
guy thank you from jonathan dear michael
my mother divorced my father 13 years
ago and divorced her second husband
three years ago both of them are good
men and neither gave her any real reason
to leave cheating abuse etc i recently
told her if she ever got married again i
want nothing to do with it or her next
husband is that a reasonable position i
still have a relationship with her but
it's rocky i feel she's made a mockery
of marriage and another one wouldn't be
legitimate before the lord and so i
don't want to participate in a
semi-blasphemous charade well
yeah harsh but fair mostly fair i guess
a marriage if she were to engage in what
seems like a third marriage it could be
a legitimate marriage if her first two
marriages are annulled if they are found
not to have been legitimate marriages in
the first place not just because she
changed her mind afterwards and so
somehow you'd be blessing the divorce
but if there is an annulment
investigation and it is found that her
marriages were not legitimate in the
first place then then what seems to be a
third marriage would be
legit
but it just sounds like your mom's got
some problems you know and i know people
like that
got some friends and relatives like that
and they make a huge mess of their lives
and it's very unfair to children and
it's unfortunate for them sometimes they
have kind of mental problems that lead
to this bipolar or something like that
but it's it's very unfortunate you
certainly
aren't under no obligation really nor
should you participate
in something that makes a mockery of
marriage you know i don't think you
would be
uh
required to show up to to this sort of
thing
but you do have an obligation
under the fourth commandment to honor
your mother and your father you know you
you do have a filial obligation to them
and so i wouldn't cut your mother off
and i wouldn't be a huge jerk about it i
would state your position in
charity and love and kindness and truth
but
but she's your mother you only get one
of them you know doesn't mean you got to
do evil things doesn't mean you got to
ruin your life because of your mother
but you do have obligations to her and
it's
if she's making a mess of her life you
should try to fix it and you should at
least be there for her
as long as that does not implicate you
in doing doing immoral things from sarah
hey michael i have a date this weekend
we're watching a movie and since it's
halloween we are going to watch a scary
movie insert spooky ghost sound effect
what scary movie is your favorite and if
you don't have a favorite just list a
few
of the top ones and i can see which one
is free to stream huh thanks well there
are a lot of i mean the best one
recently is a quiet place the first the
second one's fine too but the first one
is actually really quite good
um
that one's good the i remember the
exorcism of emily rose being
particularly good
i did like that movie uh in terms of the
slashers just the cheap kind of slasher
movies i always got a kick out of
halloween it was just
so what it is it was just so that genre
it's not a particularly good movie i
love the shining the shining is a great
movie
there's another one that came out a few
years ago
that basically the punch line was just
they were being
bedeviled by satanists it was pretty
straightforward movie that was there was
good too i forget the name of it though
so those are all good if i had to pick
one like spooky movie though i'd
probably do the shining from nick
oh no
hi michael me again
hi nick it's been a while i feel like
you and i have built a level of comfort
and trust so i'm going to tell you
something that i've hidden my whole life
like a secret i've kept locked away
recently i started dating again not
really for me personally it just felt
selfish not getting out there when so
many women are lonely or returning to
lesbianism this is where my bro to bro
confession with you begins i met this
girl i spit some game and she ended the
she ended the clothing optional
adventure before it began
because she only dates tall guys and i'm
five foot and three fourths
five
five oh five sev bruce they cut off the
five seven and three fourths okay okay
i feel like this was god's only mistake
my vibe and persona is at least six
three and i am not
my question is uh our height preference
is just something i should accept when i
meet babes or is height discrimination
wrong and is this just a total shallow
harlot who will end up marrying a washed
up nba player on his fifth try
sincerely your other under six foot
brother
nick i you know that was one of the
cleaner messages you've sent into i
don't know is nick even just one person
or have has the audience just started
channeling the spirit of nick and
they're all i don't know maybe it's just
one guy um
to your question nick
heitism
is look i say i'm not i'm not 6'3 i'm
not a basketball player okay
i say this
in a spirit of love
heightism is just something you're gonna
have to deal with buddy you know i think
actually your view i can't believe i'm
saying this your view on this is
actually probably pretty good maybe the
good lord didn't make you six four nick
because you're such a lothario you're so
impressive you're obviously
god's gift to women uh by your own
telling
that uh it was just it's a little hurdle
to to level out the playing field make
it fair recognizing that suffering can
be a very sanctifying event i think you
could probably use a little
sanctification nick but maybe maybe
you're on the right track
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show happy halloween see you
monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin